in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some music masters with
their connection quota will we hit the
high notes stay tuned to find out
Meister was adopting the latest and
greatest in serverless technology and
had recently moved some of their systems
from compute engine to cloud functions
sadly one challenge popped up as the new
function started to eclipse their
connection quota but wait a minute
connection quota see most likely your
GCF calls will be doing a lot of
external RPC calls uh querying API is
fetching proxy resources etc etc each
outbound request is a connection and
there's a quota involved with it so if
each one of your functions is doing ten
RPC calls and you're running a million
instances quota might get in your way
thankfully GCF has a little feature that
allows you to reuse connections between
invitations of a cloud function if
you're fetching from the same host you
don't have to pay the extra overhead of
their new connection since it's already
opened for example code like this was
being used by Meister to fetch an asset
from one of their databases although
this code is pretty standard the HTTP
request has no persistence which means
that it performs a new connection on
every function invocation we can fix
this and maintain persistent connections
by using a custom HTTP agent with me
keep alive option after running a small
test the cloud functions API quota page
in the cloud console shows a huge
improvement between the two code paths
and also has the side effect of
decreasing DNS resolve switch by the way
is also something you have to provision
quota for now in my opinion one of the
strongest things about GCF is its
out-of-the-box support and helper
libraries to the rest of Google Cloud
however because those api's generally
make RPC calls through socket
connections we can run into the same
problem with connection quota for
example when using the cloud pub/sub api
their code was using one connection in
two DNS queries per invocation
however by moving the pub/sub variable
to a global state and declaring it Const
we can remove unnecessary connections
and DNS queries re sharing the
connection with these simple changes
Meister was able to get an 8x reduction
in connection and DNS usage to learn
more about our changes check out the
article linked in the description
below and don't forget to check out the
rest of the cloud performance Atlas
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts